En cierto sentido, la clase de hoy
está dedicada, en cierto modo,
a unir los cabos sueltos.
Recibí de ustedes 29 páginas
escritas a un solo espacio,
llenas de las preguntas que hicieron en
el ejercicio dirigido nueve.
Voy a responder a todas
ellas en detalle.
De hecho, no voy a responder a
todas ellas en detalle.
Voy a escoger algunas de las que creo
que son de interés general
y recibiré con gusto a aquellos
cuyas preguntas no responda,
a pasar por mi oficina.
Una forma de pensar en lo que haremos
cuando encontremos este
artículo en clase es pensar
en lo que hacen cuando ven un
edificio por primera vez,
por decir, la Torre Eiffel,
y se les dan guías
acerca de cómo extraer el
sentido de ese edificio.
Una de las cosas que traté de hacer
para cada uno de los artículos
o libros que leímos fue darles una
sensación de forma general.
Darles una sensación de lo que es
distintivo acerca de eso,
darles la sensación de cómo se
estructura de manera interna
y de qué manera la
estructura interna determina
qué es lo que podemos hacer
con ese artículo
y qué puede iluminar dicho artículo.
En ciertos casos, traté de darles
un sentido del vecindario
en el que es posible
encontrar ese artículo,
al igual que hablar sobre
la Torre Eiffel,
podría enseñarles en qué
parte de París se ubica.
O bien podría tratar de darles
una sensación de la forma
en que ese artículo se relaciona con
otros enfoques del mismo tipo:
de qué manera la Torre
Eiffel se relaciona
con otros edificios
monumentales icónicos.
La pregunta de la relación entre
los artículos individuales
que leímos para hoy y el
marco más grande
es sobre todo algo que analizaré
en la clase del jueves.
No obstante, veré parte
de eso al comparar
y contrastar las visiones de la
filosofía política de hoy en día.
Lo que quiero hacer un poco más hoy en
día es ver algunos detalles
de algunos de los argumentos,
artículos y escritos
que hemos considerado en la
forma en que podríamos ver
en parte de un edificio y preguntar
cómo se estructura ahí,
reconocer que al hacerlo, hay muchas
otras partes del edificio
a las que no les prestamos atención.
O podríamos preguntar,
con respecto de qué tipo de problema
se construyó el edificio.
Estos son los planos para
la Torre Eiffel.
Así, el objetivo de la clase de hoy es,
con respecto del número
de las preguntas
que hicieron en el
ejercicio dirigido nueve,
ver algunos de los detalles de
algunos de los argumentos y,
en menor medida, ponerlos en un
contexto más grande.
Al hacerlo, para mí es
importante reconocer
que hicieron una tremenda cantidad
de preguntas interesantes
y que ni siquiera me voy a
acercar a responder.
Hubo una gran cantidad de
preguntas muy interesantes
acerca de las conexiones entre la
filosofía política de Rawls y Nozick,
por ejemplo, y la
Constitución de Estados
Unidos.
No voy a tener nada que decir sobre eso.
Hubo preguntas sobre las infancias
de los diversos autores
que hemos leído y que pudieron haber
afectado sus puntos de vista.
Tampoco tengo nada que decir sobre eso.
Y tal vez mi pregunta favorita.
Me preguntaron:
si yo fuera a tomar un
café en el Blue State
con alguno de los autores que
leímos este semestre,
¿a cuál escogería?
Supongo que no sería Robert Nozick,
porque no querría ir al Blue State.
Pero más allá de eso,
supongo que es difícil
responder a esa pregunta.
Así, lo que voy a hacer hoy se divide
básicamente entres partes.
En la primera parte grande de la clase,
voy a analizar con algún detalle
un artículo que quedó
pendiente de hace dos clases.
Es decir, voy a hablar un poco sobre
Cass Sunstein y las normas.
Y voy a usarlo como una forma de
transición a ciertos acertijos
que enfrentamos sobre
heurística y la pregunta
de cómo encajan dentro de la
tradición del procesamiento doble.
Pero también será un importante
enfoque para la clase del jueves.
No se decepcionen
si no pongo su pregunta en esa sección.
Luego cerraré esa sección
identificando para ustedes
un conjunto de cursos que
podrían interesarles
si esa fue la parte de la clase que
más les llamó la atención.
Luego diremos algunas cosas
sobre la sección de filosofía
política del curso.
Y cerraré la clase de hoy con la
sección de filosofía moral del curso,
indicando cada vez lugares a
cuáles ir a continuación,
si les conmovieron particularmente
algunas de las lecturas que hicimos.
Comencemos con una
introducción bastante
detallada
sobre lo que Cass Sunstein dijo
en un artículo de 1996
y que leímos para la clase
del martes pasado.
Lo que Sunstein intenta hacer en esa
pieza es identificar las formas
en las que nuestras actitudes hacia
ciertos tipos de conductas
por nuestra parte y por
parte de los demás
hacia ciertos tipos de
decisiones nuestras y de otros,
se ven afectadas por lo que él
llama, tomando de un gran cuerpo
de literatura sociológica,
normas sociales.
Las normas sociales son básicamente
actitudes sociales de aprobación
y desaprobación que especifican,
a través los tipos de mecanismos
tácitos que los seres humanos,
como primates sociales, tienen
para expresar la aprobación
y desaprobación de las acciones
propias y de los demás.
Es decir, las actitudes sociales de
aprobación y desaprobación
que especifican lo que debería hacerse
y lo que no debería hacerse.
Cosas sutiles, como expresiones
faciales matizadas, evasiones,
todas las pistas sociales
a las que somos extraordinariamente
sensibles en la infancia,
en nuestros primeros años
y a las que somos absoluta
y exquisitamente
sensibles en la primaria y
en la secundaria.
Y a las que continuamos siendo sensibles
a lo largo de toda nuestra vida.
Lo que Sunstein señala es que
nuestras normas sociales
determinan los significados sociales.
Es decir, determinan las
actitudes y compromisos
que señala un tipo
particular de conducta.
Así, señala, si se abrochan el
cinturón de seguridad
en un país en el que el uso de
éste no es la norma,
entonces al hacerlo se expresa
una crítica implícita
a la capacidad del conductor de
navegar el automóvil
de manera eficaz por la carretera.
Abrocharse el cinturón es un insulto.
Cuando mi familia y yo rentamos
autos en Europa oriental,
de donde es mi esposo, por lo general
los autos de renta vienen,
si no se rentan en una agencia grande,
con una pequeña placa metálica
que se inserta en la hebilla del
cinturón sin tener que usar éste,
de modo que el molesto ruido se apaga
y no es necesario usar el
insultante cinturón.
Por otro lado, en los países donde
el cinturón es la norma,
y donde de hecho es la ley,
el no abrocharlo se vuelve una
expresión de falta de respeto.
Cuando mi familia estaba creciendo,
para mi gran vergüenza,
separaba las cáscaras vegetales
de sus envolturas de papel
y los ponía en el patio trasero,
en un montón de composta.
El significado social del
montón de composta
en el Massachusetts suburbano
de la década de 1970
era de no ser normal.
Tal vez era una expresión de que
éramos más conscientes
socialmente que nuestros vecinos, lo
cual podría considerarse
que éramos mejores que
nuestros vecinos.
Pero sea lo que fuere, no era
una forma de encajar.
Hoy en día, en grandes
partes de Estados Unidos,
un montón de composta o llevar
una bolsa reciclable,
o reemplazar un foco con otro de larga
duración y amplio espectro,
simplemente expresa respeto
por el medio ambiente
más que se una actitud extraña.
Mi sobrino húngaro, que vino
de visita este verano,
llevaba una camiseta de Iron Maiden,
que pensaba que estaba de moda,
y que en Budapest era una expresión
de estar a la vanguardia.
En nuestro entorno
suburbano de Connecticut,
sus acciones con frecuencia se
percibían erróneamente
como de rebeldía, debido a
las señales sociales
que su ropa transmitía.
Así, la razón por la que ustedes
leyeron el artículo de Sunstein
en el contexto de nuestra discusión
de la filosofía política,
fue señalar cuántas más capas
de complejidad existen
cuando comenzamos a pensar
qué tipo de estructuras
sociales son legítimas.
Además, hubo una cuestión
específica acerca del artículo de
Sunstein, que surgió en el contexto de
nuestra página de retroalimentación,
acerca de lo que quiero hablar un
poco a modo de transición.
Así, uno de los estudiantes
preguntó si podía caracterizar
el complicado argumento de Sunstein
sobre la disposición de
pagar y la de permitir.
Así, lo que estamos haciendo ahora
es ver el soporte particular
de un argumento muy especifico.
Así, podrán recordar que
en ese artículo
Sunstein introduce una discusión
de lo que se conoce como
el efecto de dotación, que es
básicamente la tendencia
de los seres humanos a demandar más
para renunciar a un objeto
de su propiedad de lo que estarían
dispuestos a pagar para adquirirlo.
Y el término para definir
por cuánto está alguien
dispuesto a vender algo es WTA,
la Disposición a aceptar un pago
(Willingness To Accept payment),
en tanto que el término
para lo que alguien
está dispuesto a pagar por
un objeto es WTP,
Disposición a aceptar un pago
(Willingness To Pay).
Resulta ser que si tengo una
hermosa taza para café de Yale,
que quiero venderles, nuestras
evaluaciones de pago
con frecuencia serán diferentes.
Muy bien podría decir que no me
desharé de mi hermosa taza
por menos de $10.
En tanto ustedes podrían decir,
"no compraré tu horrible taza
vieja por más de $5".
Incluso si, cuando
alteremos la situación
y ustedes tengan la taza y yo no,
nuestras respuestas se invierten.
Yo no compraré su horrible
taza por más de $5
y ustedes no se desharán de
ella por menos de $10.
Ahora Sunstein, hace 15 años
en este artículo,
formula la hipótesis que lo
que explica este efecto
es de manera primaria algo acerca
de las normas sociales.
Parece que, por lo menos
en cierta medida,
estaba equivocado.
Al menos estaba equivocado en cuanto
a que las normas sociales
explican del todo estos fenómenos.
Debido a que la investigación realizada
en el laboratorio de Laurie Santos
en esta misma universidad
en los últimos cinco años parece
sugerir que es posible encontrar
algo parecido al efecto de
dotación en los monos capuchinos.
Una tendencia a valorar más lo
propio que lo ajeno,
incluso cuando los objetos
son idénticos.
Una vez dicho esto, incluso
hay razones para pensar
que Sunstein tiene algo cuando afirma
que la disposición a pagar y a
permitir la distinción,
en algunas formas de seguir algo
acerca del significado social.
Así, señala que, en una
serie de estudios
dentro del contexto de la economía
conductual con sujetos WEIRD
cerca de la Universidad de Chicago,
al menos para adultos de países
occidentales (Western), educados,
industrializados, ricos y democráticos,
parece que la asimetría es
bastante profunda.
Así que describió este estudio,
cuyos detalles pensé que
analizaría pero no va a ser así,
en el que ven una
asimetría bastante radical
en la disposición del sujeto a
adquirir un objeto de otra persona,
o bien parte de un objeto
propiedad de otra persona.
La respuesta de Sunstein a
estos tipos de casos
es sugerir que la diferencia
aquí tiene mucho que ver
con las normas y significados sociales.
Así, estar dispuesto, por ejemplo,
a aceptar cierta cantidad de dinero
para permitir la
extinción de una especie
tiene un significado social
muy distinto que,
aunque podría pensarse que
estructuralmente es lo mismo,
aceptar, o estar dispuesto a pagar
una cierta cantidad de dinero
para impedir la extinción
de dicha especie.
Ya sea que considere como línea de
base el estado del mundo
en el que la especie está extinta
o si se considera donde
ésta está presente
y la función de ustedes es salvarla,
resulta ser que se afecta la
evaluación de la persona.
Sunstein sugiere, en el articulo
de manera más general,
que varias de nuestras acciones,
numerosas decisiones,
se impulsan al menos en parte
por el significado social
interno y externo.
Como consecuencia, el mecanismo eficaz
para influir en las
acciones y decisiones
es hacerlo en los significados sociales
de dichas acciones y decisiones.
Así, sugiere, resulta ser una
función inevitable de gobierno
regular la conducta por medio de la
afirmación, la introducción
o la desaprobación de ciertos
tipos de significado social.
Y abordamos el tema de este tipo de
control no racional indirecto
en el contexto del análisis de Platón
sobre la censura.
Ahora bien, esta distinción entre la
disposición a pagar y la disposición
a permitir, cuyos detalles haremos
a un lado por el momento,
pueden usarse para pensar en
uno de los ejemplos,
de lo que hablamos en muchas clases
y de lo que hablaremos de
nuevo el jueves.
Es decir, el hecho de que hay una
innegable tendencia de las personas,
incluyendo a este grupo,
para responder en forma diferente al
caso clásico del carrito,
en el que una persona desvía un
carrito de sus rieles
cuando está por golpear a cinco a
otra donde golpeará a uno solo,
y los casos que suponen empujar
a alguien de un puente.
Así, cuando el primero entre
ustedes generó solamente
15% de respuestas diciendo que estaba
prohibido girar el carrito,
el segundo caso en el que se les pidió
empujar al hombre gordo del puente,
por lo tanto matando a uno
para salvar a cinco,
generó una conclusión del
78% entre ustedes
de que ese acto estaba prohibido.
En la próxima clase hablaremos mucho
de la forma de conciliar las intuiciones
respecto de casos particulares
con un compromiso de
principio más general.
Pero lo que quiero hacer ahora es,
a modo de responder un par de preguntas,
señalarles tres formas diferentes
que se podría responder
a lo que ocurre en esta asimetría.
Uno podría,
haciendo uso del vocabulario que
Sunstein acaba de introducir,
decir que lo que ocurre en el
caso del hombre gordo
es un caso en el que se le pide a
alguien aceptar un costo.
Aceptar el costo de la muerte de una
persona a fin de salvar cinco.
E tanto que lo que ocurre en el
caso del interruptor
es que se pide a alguien pagar un costo:
algo que no fue parte del
cálculo, para comenzar,
de pagar el costo de la muerte de una
persona para salvar a cinco.
Sabemos, como cuestión de
teoría general,
que la forma en que funciona la
responsabilidad en el primate humano,
y tal vez en los no humanos,
que el costo de aceptar algo
parece mayor para nosotros
que el costo de pagar.
Así, quizá lo que está
ocurriendo en los casos del carrito
es que los asimilamos,
por medio de un mecanismo heurístico
que usamos con frecuencia,
para un tipo familiar de
proceso de razonamiento,
que puede rastrear nuestros
compromisos morales o no.
O tal vez como se sugirió
originalmente al mostrar los casos,
lo que aquí rastreamos en
nuestras diferentes respuestas
es una distinción profunda
y moralmente real
entre violar los derechos y
considerar la utilidad,
donde en los casos en que interviene
la violación de los derechos,
matar o dejar morir a una persona
a fin de salvar a cinco
es moralmente erróneo.
En los casos en que los
derechos no intervienen,
dejar morir o matar a una
persona para salvar a cinco
es moralmente aceptable.
O tal vez lo que pasa en este caso es,
como lo sugiere Josh Greene con base en
su trabajo de neuroimaginería,
que uno de los casos en los que
respondemos emocionalmente
y en el otro respondemos de
manera racional.
Lo que la primera y tercera
respuesta tienen en común,
pero no la segunda: es decir, que las
dos respuestas que sugerimos
que deberíamos tomar como lo
sugieren nuestras respuestas
diferencialmente informativas al caso del
hombre gordo y del espectador,
es que al pensar en uno de
estos casos primariamente
con un modo de pensamiento
y el otro primariamente con el
otro modo de pensamiento.
A lo largo del curso, hemos
introducido el hecho de que,
en todas las tradiciones
intelectuales ha habido una
sugerencia
de que el conocimiento humano del
mundo procede en diversas formas.
El conocimiento científico
vernáculo contemporáneo
utiliza la noción del
procesamiento doble.
Sugiere que hay dos sistemas: El
sistema 1 y el sistema 2.
Donde el sistema 1 es primitivo desde
el punto de vista evolutivo
y lo compartimos con los
animales no humanos,
en tanto que el sistema 2 es
evolutivamente reciente y compartido,
si es que se comparte con algún animal,
sólo con aquellos próximos a
nosotros en el árbol evolutivo.
El sistema 1 es
inconsciente o
preconsciente,
en tanto que el sistema 2 es consciente.
El sistema 1 es automático, en tanto
que el sistema 2 es controlado.
El sistema 1 no lleva esfuerzo, en tanto
que el sistema 2 sí lo lleva.
El sistema 1 es rápido, en tanto
que el sistema 2 es lento.
El sistema 1 es asociativo,
en tanto que el sistema 2
se basa en reglas.
Ahora, una de las cosas que hemos
hecho a lo largo del curso
es ver diversas formas de
lograr la distinción
que obtiene esta versión
particular sin tratar de decidir
cuál de estos marcos es el más
útil en todos los contextos.
Pero más bien, al reconocer
que en ciertos dominios
puede ser útil hablar,
como lo hace Platón,
del espíritu y del apetito que
jalan en una dirección
y la razón en el otro.
Esto podría ser en ciertos
contextos para hablar como lo hago,
causando que ciertos tipos de
conductas no reflexivas
en tanto que la creencia hace que
ciertos tipos reflectivos.
En algunos contextos puede ser
útil hablar de heurística
como causante de que respondamos en
una forma de cognición,
o reflexión, plena que nos hace
responder de otra forma.
Pero es importante saber que al elegir
dos o tres formas particulares
que observamos en esta
distinción suprema,
que descuidamos murar a los muchos,
muchos otros tipos de cuentas
de procesamiento doble.
Aquí hay quince, más o menos,
tomados del artículo de Evans,
que leímos a mediados de enero.
Y que para los propósitos de
nuestra discusión en este curso,
las similitudes entre
estos puntos de vista
es más relevante que las diferencias.
Sin embargo, si les intriga este
conjunto de preguntas,
que acabo de ver de pasada,
hay numerosos lugares a los
cuales ir a continuación.
La mayoría de los cursos ofrecidos
por el programa de ciencia
cognitiva mira los tipos de
problemas que acabo de analizar.
¿De qué modo afectan el
razonamiento humano
las características
estructurales del cerebro?
¿En qué medida podemos
sistematizar los tipos de errores
que los seres humanos parecen
cometer en el razonamiento?
¿En qué medida estos tipos de
errores, o lo que llamamos errores,
son de hecho medios eficaces
para navegar los diversos
tipos de entornos?
También pueden ver estos
tipos de preguntas
en el contexto de la psicología
social, cognitiva, de desarrollo,
y donde habrá numerosos cursos que se
ofrecerán el año próximo
en psicología que irán
mucho más a fondo
en las preguntas que acabo de mencionar.
La Escuela de Administración ofrece
cursos en economía conductual,
abiertos a estudiantes de licenciatura
con los antecedentes requeridos.
Y en el contexto del
departamento de filosofía,
hay cursos históricos que ven
con seriedad y a fondo
exclusivamente a Platón.
Ciertamente, este semestre hay un curso
que solamente lee La
República de Platón.
Hay cursos que ven a
Aristóteles o su ética.
Cursos que ven cada uno de los
autores que hemos considerado.
Tan intrigados por lo que
acabamos de hablar,
con tantos lugares a los cuáles ir.
El segundo gran grupo de temas que
quiero abordar con preguntas.
Casi una tercera parte de las
preguntas trataban,
tal vez porque ocurrió
hace tan poco tiempo,
analizar de nuevo la relación
entre Nozick y Rawls
y para decir algo, tal vez,
acerca de la forma
en que esto encaja con Hobbes y la
teoría del contrato social.
Así, tomando de mi colega Thomas Pogge,
hay una útil forma de pensar en la
diferencia entre tres de ellas.
Primero les daré una descripción
general de la diferencia
y luego trataré de presentarles una
explicación sistemática
de dónde Hobbes, Rawls y Nozick
son similares y diferentes.
Los tres trabajan en lo que se conoce
como la tradición del contrato social.
Los tres opinan que hay un
cierto tipo de interés
por parte de los seres
humanos a contratarse
dentro de cierto tipo de estructura
social incluso si al hacerlo
ceden parte de su libertad.
Hobbes afirma que para nosotros
es de utilidad prudencial
participar en un contrato social.
Estamos mejor de como estaríamos
si no formáramos parte de un estado.
Pero el estado de la
naturaleza al que Hobbes apela
es estrictamente imaginario.
Es un contrato hipotético, cuyo valor
para nosotros es prudencial.
Rawls sugiere que es de utilidad
moral para nosotros tomar parte
en el tipo de contrato social que
representa el estado de Rawls.
De manera imaginaria vamos a
la posición original
detrás del velo de ignorancia.
Al hacerlo, proponemos algo valioso
desde el punto de vista moral.
En contraste con Rawls, a Nozick
le preocupan las cosas
que en realidad llegan a existir.
Pero al igual que Rawls,
le interesa el tipo de
justificación moral que
proporciona.
Así, en tanto que a Hobbes le interesa
lo que un contrato hipotético
nos dice acerca de lo que es
prudente para nosotros,
a Rawls le interesa lo que un
contrato hipotético nos dice
de lo que es moral y a
Nozick le interesa
que un tipo de conjunto de
eventos históricos,
donde está con respecto
de la moralidad.
Comencemos mirando el
argumento de Hobbes.
En el Leviatán, Hobbes nos presenta
lo que llama un estado de la naturaleza.
Una situación imaginaria en la que
"el estilo de vida que habría si no
hubiera un poder común al miedo".
Donde la vida es "solitaria, pobre,
desagradable, brutal y breve".
Y sugiere que nuestro
objetivo prudencial,
que para nosotros de útil,
es escapar del estado de la naturaleza.
¿Por qué? Porque todos
nosotros tenemos un
"miedo a la muerte, el deseo
de una vida cómoda,
y la esperanza de que con nuestro
trabajo la obtendremos".
Pero, dice Hobbes, eso da origen,
si pensamos en el hecho
de que estar en un estado de la
naturaleza es malo para nosotros,
para varias conclusiones obligadas
desde el punto de vista racional,
de las que analizamos tres.
Éstas son lo que Hobbes llama
leyes de la naturaleza.
Las cosas, que nos damos cuenta
que la racionalidad demanda
de nosotros si tenemos el objetivo
prudencial de una vida cómoda.
En particular, necesitamos buscar la paz
si hay posibilidades de obtenerla
y si no nos reservamos el
derecho de guerra.
Primera ley de la naturaleza.
Necesitamos ceder nuestros derechos
en la medida en que los demás
quieran hacer lo mismo.
Segunda ley de la naturaleza.
Necesitamos llevar a cabo
nuestras alianzas;
es decir, respetar nuestras promesa,
suponiendo que los demás
quieran hacer lo mismo.
Pero al hacerlo hay un
problema estructural.
El problema estructural es el que
expresa el dilema del prisionero.
Debido a ello, dice Hobbes, la
única manera que podemos hacer
lo que el racionalismo demanda de
nosotros: buscar la paz,
ceder nuestros derechos y
celebrar acuerdos;
actuando por tanto d¿sobre la
primera mitad de estas cláusulas,
es si instituimos un
gobierno autoritario.
Un poder civil suficiente para
obligar a la no deserción
en un dilema del prisionero.
Observen los cuatro pasos.
Porque voy a analizar éstos a
continuación con Rawls
y después con Nozick.
Estamos interesados en una situación,
una conclusión mandada de
manera racionalmente
y un mecanismo mandado estructuralmente.
¿Cómo maneja esto Rawls?
Rawls dice, miren.
Consideremos la siguiente
situación hipotética.
La posición original, donde estamos
detrás del velo de ignorancia,
sin saber dónde estaremos
en la sociedad,
y elegimos las estructuras básicas
que regirán a nuestra sociedad.
El objetivo que
comprometimos en esta
actividad
es articular las condiciones
de una sociedad justa.
¿Por qué?
Porque la justicia es la primera virtud
de las instituciones sociales
así como la verdad es la primera
virtud de los sistemas teóricos".
Es el objetivo de articular una
filosofía política
para proponer uno que respete
nuestras normas morales.
Del mismo modo que el objetivo de Hobbes
al articular las limitaciones
que rigen una sociedad
política legítima
para identificar la que respeta
las normas de prudencia.
Entonces, ¿cuál es la
conclusión mandada racionalmente
de tomar esta situación hipotética
y este objetivo particular?
Bueno, dice Rawls, al igual que
el pensamiento de Hobbes,
pensar en la estructura del estado de
la naturaleza que nos dan,
a través de la racionalidad, las
tres leyes de la naturaleza.
Así piensa también Rawls,
pensando en la estructura de
la posición original
con la meta de desarrollar
una sociedad moral,
que nos dan los principios
de la justicia.
En particular, el primer
principio de libertad igual:
bajo ninguna circunstancia están
los principios fundamentales
del que se sacrifica para el
beneficio de muchos.
Y segundo, que en la medida en
que hay desigualdades
en la sociedad, éstos se asociarán
con posiciones abiertas a todos
y de tal manera que sea ventajosa
para los menos favorecidos.
Además, Rawls piensa no sólo en
una situación hipotética
y el objetivo moral y la
conclusión mandada racionalmente
que podemos extraer de eso, pero
también acerca del tipo de mecanismo,
el tipo de estructura que la
sociedad nos dice que tengamos.
Su sugerencia es que se
convierte aproximadamente
es una con igualdad y derechos y
obligaciones básicos.
Libertad de expresión, de pensamiento;
una responsabilidad igual para
hacer una contribución
al mantenimiento de la
comunidad como un todo.
Y debido a los hechos acerca de la
eficiencia, Rawls está listo,
al menos de manera tentativa,
apoyar como un mecanismo
eficaz hacia esto;
una economía de mercado con cierta
tendencia a la redistribución.
Observen que es un argumento casi
paralelo al de Hobbes.
Tomamos una situación hipotética.
Tenemos un objetivo.
Razonamos nuestra manera de
pensar en la situación
y determinar ciertos tipos
de limitaciones.
Y luego identificamos el tipo de
estructura que nos da.
A continuación veamos lo que nos da
en el contexto de Nozick.
A Nozick no le interesa una
situación hipotética,
sino una histórica.
En particular, le interesa lo
que deberíamos hacer
acerca del hecho de que una
distribución particular de recursos
como consecuencia de una serie de
transferencias justas.
Una serie de transferencias en las
que la propiedad se adquirió
en una forma legítima y se
transfirió legítimamente,
sin importar qué produjo tal patrón.
Observen que, si bien sólo
leímos el análisis de Nozick
de la justicia en las
posesiones y, en consecuencia,
observamos una pregunta
más bien estrecha
de bajo qué condiciones es
legítimo tener propiedades,
que el argumento de Nozick con
respecto de las propiedades
puede generalizarse con respecto de
cualquier tipo de decisión
que las personas tomen.
Lo que hace legítimas las
propiedades en la imagen de Nozick
es que son resultado de un
proceso legítimo.
Como consecuencia, cualquier tipo
de contrato que celebremos
en una forma en que Nozick llama
libre albedrío termina estando
en la misma categoría histórica.
Así, lo que interesa a
Nozick es la pregunta:
dado que las cosas como cuestión
de contingencia histórica
terminan de la forma en que están
en términos de distribución de
bienes y de contratos,
¿qué tipo de fuerza moral tiene?
El objetivo de Nozick es determinar si la
distribución de las posesiones,
es decir, propiedades; y contratos, es
decir, compromisos; es legítima.
Y su sugerencia es que,
en la medida que la propiedad se
adquiere y transfiere justamente,
entonces sean cuales sean los
resultados, es una distribución justa.
Recordarán que vimos con cierto detalle
la idea de la adquisición justa de
Nozick, en la que básicamente dice,
un objeto se sostiene de
manera legítima
en una forma en la que el valor
que se agrega al objeto
hace que su posesión de él
dejen a los demás mejor
de como debían estar si no se
hubiera adquirido el objeto.
Y donde las transferencias
son cualesquiera
en las que se participa de
manera voluntaria.
Un resultado de eso, como lo vimos en
el ejemplo de Wilt Chamberlain,
es que incluso si comenzamos
con una distribución
perfectamente pareja de los bienes a
lo largo de las personas,
casi se garantiza que
terminaremos con una desigual.
Y observen que exactamente el
mismo tipo de argumento
que puede elevarse para la
distribución de la propiedad
distribución de obligaciones.
Así, a Nozick le interesa la
situación histórica.
Tiene un objetivo moral, que es
determinar si la distribución es justa.
La conclusión que extrae, como
resultado de pensar en la estructura,
es que toda intervención de las
distribuciones generadas con justicia
de las propiedades o los contratos es
una violación de derechos.
Después de todo,
las únicas cosas que preocupan si
las propiedades son justas,
en la imagen de Nozick,
es si se adquirieron o
transfirieron con justicia.
Y el hecho que, como cuestión de los
problemas de coordinación
del tipo que enfrentaremos en el
problema de los comunes,
el hecho que inevitablemente resultará
en distribuciones desiguales
no es relevante para el tipo
de imagen histórica
que tiene Nozick.
Asimismo,
el hecho de que como resultado de
la contingencia histórica,
puedo terminar contratada en una forma
que me deje subordinada a ustedes no
es, de acuerdo con Nozick,
en modo alguno injusta porque
ninguna intervención
en un proceso generado con justicia,
puede realizarse sin
violar los derechos.
Así, el mecanismo mandado
estructuralmente
que Nozick termina defendiendo es
el del estado mínimo.
¿Y cuál es la imagen entre
nuestros filósofos políticos?
La idea es esta:
A Hobbes le interesa pensar en un estado
hipotético de la naturaleza,
considerado desde la
perspectiva de la prudencia,
nos dice que es racional.
Lo que nos dice que es racional son
ciertas leyes de la naturaleza,
cuyo cumplimiento es posible solamente
mediante la introducción de
un estado autoritario.
Rawls nos pide que pensemos
hipotéticamente
desde la posición del velo
de la ignorancia,
lo que se tomaría para tener
una sociedad moral,
concluye que se regiría por los
principios de justicia,
e identifica como un
mecanismo que llamé
porque no había mucho
espacio, "Suecia".
Y Nozick pregunta qué podemos hacer,
dado que una distribución actual
surgió como resultado
de las transferencias justas
y concluye que si nuestro objetivo
es respetar los derechos,
entonces el único estado que es
legítimo es el estado mínimo.
Pasamos más o menos cuatro clases
en filosofía política.
¿Adónde ir si quieren más?
El departamento de Filosofía ofrece
cursos de filosofía política,
tanto cursos de investigación
y cursos en cada una de las
personas que leímos.
Pueden tomar un curso de
investigación de filosofía
política,
desde Platón hasta Nozick.
O bien, pueden tomar un curso
sobre cualquiera de los
autores en lo particular.
Asimismo, el departamento de
Ciencia Política
ofrece cursos
estructurados
históricamente
sobre cada uno de los autores.
Virtualmente todos los cursos enlistados
en el departamento de Ética,
Política y Economía abordará
los tipos de cuestiones que
mencioné en este diagrama.
Y en el contexto del
departamento de Economía
y ciertamente en tres o cuatro de
los otros departamentos,
pueden pensar en la teoría de juegos
como una forma de
representar estas
estructuras
o pensar en la política en el
contexto de un marco económico.
Son las 11:19.
Integraré la discusión de moralidad
y las respuestas es estas preguntas en
nuestra clase final del jueves.
Pero espero que
incluso si no respondía las 500
preguntas que me hicieron hoy,
que la clase les haya
dado cierto sentido
sobre la forma en que encajan entre
sí algunas de las piezas.
Continuaremos el jueves.